you guys are here today to talk about
Imperial dreams it's lovely to see it
and answer the premiere of the film
what's it been like so far we're all
poppin or some cherries together over
yeah yeah we are it's amazing so far
it's great weather
it's a great culture here yeah Robert
Redford are pioneers definitely created
something that's so special and there's
just a whole lot of people that love
film love art and it's a great feel
festive all to come to I've been
enjoying myself I went skiing for the
first time yesterday I'm Pro okay about
five times and but it's all good I've
been I've been enjoying myself and I got
to see see a film and uh hopefully I
continued this way a great time I know
it's been great man I was surprised by
the weather first and then when I got
here just it allows you to be a fan
again you know you can see everybody's
work and you know and just just learn
you know so that's the best part for me
just learning different things you're
enjoying it so far and now the film is
about a young guy who and his brother
half-brother who comes across many
obstacles in life doesn't he to change
his situation around and I kind of
wondered what kind of obstacles you guys
would face to get where you are now
successful young actors and and and also
sing the song motives - okay so in terms
of other obstacles personally yeah on
terms of obstacles I'd say like any
career there's a there's a doubting
moment at first way you don't know
whether you're made for it because it's
your dreams are so far-fetched and it
doesn't match the current circumstance
so you look around and you're in a
environment where you're kind of like
you know another actor I'm not working
I'm not involved in this but you know
the only thing you have want to grab on
to is your passion but it's about water
in that making that grow into something
that does establish into a career and
then whether it's luck or goal or
whatever you find yourself in there
in a place like this do an interview at
Sundance and being like hey yes the film
is great no that's done I think it's
just like wow you know this kind of just
happens you know I don't know how this
universe works but you know you just
find yourself something he just you just
feel that those obstacles that you did
face it was worth it to have that
persistence to carry on
no I agree I think your faith is
definitely tested you know so being that
you know for me and my situation um it
really was tough for me while I was in
college because I had to bound this
music and learning theater and then you
know being student at a procedure school
so it was really hard to like focus on
everything and be you know great at
everything to try to be great at
everything so but then you surround
yourself with great people you learn you
know and then it just it just becomes a
ongoing mission to get better and better
and better and you know and you have the
doubts you know and then people around
you sometimes may you know jealousy may
happen or whatever make the case may be
but you just got to pursue through it
well what keeps you going obviously
having a having success keeps people go
doesn't it and you are both having
success but what keeps you kind of
motivated through any tough times like
obviously Bambi in his brother as well
both have to keep motivated don't they
they're facing toughest obstacles along
the way yeah I know I have a I always
think when I doubt I always have this
thought of being 45 after giving up and
being in a flat or whatever having a new
job a new career and then seeing people
that Rotimi vibe being able to be friend
and various friends back in London and
thinking to myself what if I stay
persistent at this what could have
happened and I'd never want to be in
that position so I guess that kind of
haunts me in a sense and also because
when you start something it's
interesting you start to be in films or
you start to do theater when your family
support you it makes you feel like okay
I'm not just doing it but for myself
it's not about me anymore it's about
it's a mom dad sisters who are just kind
of like know you've got a kid like
you've got the you've got what it takes
to go there you know they believe it
then you know I should probably be
appreciative and believe it too I think
for me is God
you know God first like I I have my
moments of course where you're like I
don't know how far I can go how far I
can go but then just seeing the vision
that he's given me you know I have to I
have to fulfill it you know so I become
a worker for him and my family you know
I want to see them happy you know and
that when I'm happy they're happy so
it's just a constant cycle they both
mentioned family them and of course it's
a film about family isn't it very much
so and you play half-brothers as we said
so far and how did you guys get that
on-screen chemistry cuz I can see you
very easy with each other I can see that
bad bad so so first light we have to say
a big thank you to super crispy
entertainment Jonathan Schwartz and
malik fatale who's the director because
normally with films the audition process
can be so quickly you don't get time to
have chemistry reads or have Skype
meetings and with this one it was a it
was an ongoing process of getting the
tape in there doing it again and then
coming back and whether Oh Timmy was up
for the part we had a Skype call I was
just talking normally no and I was just
kind of like now that's that's the guy
like that's like I already feel a
connection with this dude at first for
his Nigeria so it's like we yeah my
mother yeah we just have a natural
though it's like you see him you see
your brother for real for real yeah and
we we just burned it on set we had
various conversations in there's
probably everything about me I've been
very transparent and embarrassed
during our conversations and and you
know hopefully that that chemistry reads
through the movie same I think when I
met John it was virtually when I saw him
I thought it was just like an instinct
connection you know and it's so funny
because the video kept chopping so we
were hey so we were guessing on like
always what is our you know I felt it
you know and then we got on set it was
just like he became my brother he became
a therapist and we became you know
mentor you know and everything and he's
so talented so you just feed off of that
so working with him has just been a
blessing you also work with two young
kids in the filter you will they play
two young twins play your young son
who's four year old a don't they now was
it like working with those two put those
two kids because they always think all
doing well with kids and animals don't
they but they seem fantastic on screen
so I've had from it working on Imperial
dreams it wasn't only a career move or
something to do with building my
artistic
muscle it actually built me and showed
me snippets of how I would be if I was a
father when I
I'm a father one day God willing the fat
yeah but I ended up just like they just
in an ether not two different kids and
it's Queens but they're two different
kids when Ethan is coming in I know if
this kid I got to be smart I gotta tell
him some cool stuff I go think Ethan you
know what happened today it's like what
John what happened today I'm gonna stop
got terms something interested I've it's
made up but has to be interested with
Justin I'm going to get into a fight
with Justin I got you know I goes
because Justin is coming in to punch you
in the face and oh yeah that's how he
shows love and for me that was kind of I
don't know I had a it was so
heartwarming working with these kids
even with some parts when they would be
like you know jumping around you want to
get them settled for the scene it it's
just amazing how you kind of I mean I'm
21 but you just got transform into this
but father thing you're like Ethan stop
Andy hey yourself saying like ah I
started looking at them like they were
my nephew's yeah well you know it's like
it felt it felt like you had to approach
each one differently you know and it was
just like all right stop stop what are
you doing
stop it you wanna see action okay you
know me so you have to really like you
know what it was it was by many talented
- I really so charming it and they
talented and they then I cute and funny
you know they sometimes you're working
in a little what son and you get tired
and you get those kids in you always
kind of like okay here comes the kids
eat just a natural energy would build up
with yeah definitely
now I'm you're working with first-time
director and she mentioned Molly didn't
you tell me what what that experiments
is I can be both of you oh I think for
me Malik Malik pushed me you know in a
good way he pushed me to basically
internalize who Wayne is and you know
completely try to remove myself from it
and I felt like his way of shooting is
so organic and so authentic so it's like
we were we were acting but the lines
just became conversation and then we
would just he'll allow us to you know
add a little bit so we would just go off
and our chemistry already was you know a
B a B a B so it just worked perfectly
and his vision is incredible so the way
he put the film together and how
everything came together has been it's
been amazing I mean I've it was
fantastic working with Malik
I guess there's something about director
leaving a whole lot of work in your
hands that just makes some magic
I remember when now sometimes when I was
dying for a note or dying for some sort
of of guide seems like Malik is on some
avatar stuff and talked about the car -
not the James Cameron and he's like it's
a visionary he's kind of like okay I'm
not gonna I'm not going to push you just
to push you but I'm gonna let you do
this on your own but this will therefore
build you as an actor and this is not
only about this project but it's about
you going on to do other things and I
feel like you know for you to implement
that into a tough schedule and into you
know the politics of film it's you got
you got to be you got to be pretty you
got to be full of love for that yeah now
when did because these young guys lives
how you went about or did how far you
went about maybe researching kind of
background could set and specific kind
of community isn't in in what's in Los
Angeles and the kind of lies that those
kind of guys lead what I came out four
weeks prior to shooting I was it out in
them Los Angeles and I mean it's always
wary when you're because I would always
say when I first received the script I
was in I was in my boys house in
Matamata him having a full English
breakfast and then the email came
through on my iPad for my people and it
was just kind of like you know got the
scripts got this audition for you to do
and for me when I first get a script it
I'm excited I read it and I'm just like
okay if it was this what's this about
and the script was great but when the
scripts is great it's so far fetched
from who you are and where you are at
the moment you kind of go I'm gonna have
to play that and so far for me what work
would I have to do and it worries you
but through the help of production in
I've seen Malik giving us advice and in
these Skype calls that we did it became
more comfortable and when I went out to
LA I was bang in the environment so I
was just literally a sponge it's just
interesting looking at a world from the
outside in because you know to a certain
extent even though this story's
universal you are free of certain
stereotypes
and you just uh see people for who they
are and then you that way you start to
build characters and then bring my own
experiences do it as well but for me um
I grew up with a lot of people who
reminded me of Wayne
so I actually sat down with one of my
friends he was a star basketball player
and had everything going for him but his
grades were horrible you know and he
couldn't go to college and now he's
working at Walgreens at home and he's a
good close friend of mine so I had to
really like ask him how do you handle
knowing how good you are knowing how
good you can be but because of money or
the circumstances you can't get there
what does that feel like
so I saw with him we talked a lot you
know so that's my first level then Malik
you know Malik just gave me points and
guidelines and what's a father who who
the research and what to think about and
then when John we were on skype and
having you know those calls it was it
was great and just started creating
Wayne you know and then from what I
thought he would what I wanted him to be
on top of that so it was just a
collaborative effort completely i
absolutely believe you guys as brothers
on on screen because I have that
fantastic chemistry between you yes
exactly we did it we know that like what
what you think of this guy thanks and
he's not listening I thought it was
pretty great so I think he's amazing
no no his it was flawless it was
flawless
honestly like um I knew it was really
good when when people in the
neighborhood were like yo like he's
nailed that you know because I'm not
from I'm not from LA you know I'm not
from what so I have an idea what I think
it may be but when they're co-signing
and saying he murdered this you know I
believe him that's Bambi you know that's
when I realized he got it and he would
go in and out of it well personally with
me do go in and out of it sometimes you
know I know like wow how do you it
reminded me like how talented you
actually is also thank you wrote in yeah
I'll take it to lunch
yeah a bonding moment
now what was it like for you doing that
accent knowing that you kind of were
working with you know American actor
knowing that you've got to get that
right knowing it's from a specific place
that the states as one office if it
community yeah I guess I guess I mean
I've been a big fan of American films in
London we grew up on American films
American TV so I feel like if British TV
was as relevant in America you grew up
on that you'd be able to go pop in and
out no so I don't think there's some
kind of supernatural hands-on the
British healing and making us do
American accents but I definitely do
would say that the challenge was not the
American but it was getting what's right
and and pronouncing certain things right
and just getting the culture because
it's so distinct it's like if you get
wrong they know that you know from here
like and I remember he now is practicing
the first two weeks a a bah-bah Ernst
who the story is loosely based on almost
like John you don't sound like you from
New Yorkers house it's like I gotta go
home visualize his stuff and get it
right but it was great working these
guys because it was support I mean ro
Timmy and anika Noni Rose were the only
two I could speak to my British just
because on set I just was American all
the time and I wouldn't do that on my
next project just because it's long
having to explain to people that you're
from place called London but it was a
great experience just kind of staying in
it and it helped me to keep concentrated
but yeah
we'll see when the film comes out hook
yeah I don't sound a Spanish now guys
what can we look forward to from you for
the future
oh I mean God willing more consistent
work you know musically have a project
coming out and I'm Assam know films and
stuff were working on now so just
hopefully good work you know good work
they were going to keep pushing for what
kind of films would you like to be
working on in the future
who would you like to go out with
ideally ideally um did you get that
transformer role you wanted to be the
world oh yeah I wanted to be the robot
yeah yeah yeah they come out yeah thing
is the red bumblebee yeah yeah bumblebee
not at this point I'm just I'm I'm just
a fan of the art so whoever but I'm a
fan of Edward Norton I like him a lot
you know I'm a huge fan of him but um
anyone anyone man I'm just a fan of it
all of it so yeah I'm over anything that
makes sense I have a film coming out
cinemas should be early summer this year
called half of the other Sun which was
premiered in Toronto Film Festival last
year and it's a story based on the
paraffin war in Nigeria and now it's me
anika Noni Rose who also stars in this
film she would tell cheerful and Tandy
Newton and so yeah that's that's coming
out I think it's going to be a showed at
a festival in LA a Pan Am American
African Film Festival it's going to be
there too so yeah I'm I'm looking
forward to that it's going to be a
different thing from Imperial dreams and
yeah just trying to just trying to do
the do the Sam Rockwell yeah keep the
variety going yeah you mentioned who is
inspired by I love Sam Rockwell Anthony
Hopkins David oh you're Lola yeah guys
are just doing all over the place you
cannot be inspired by that and make
those kind of choices I think how likely
do you think we'll be to see am attack
the block to because of course that's
one of the film that kind of launched
you didn't it yeah I don't know I don't
know I mean the last discussion I had
with Joe Cornish was back in 2012 and I
told him that I was like you know what
I've gotten older not that older but
I've grown older it's I don't know where
Moses is at the moment he's out in jail
definitely but he may have been
recruited by the men in black he's a
there's great things there so I don't
know if there's going to be a sequel for
attack the book I guess you got gotta
wait for me to do another alien movie
some sort yeah well you saw that Joe and
mentioning Joe you don't Joe turned out
apparently doing the sequel to Star Trek
into darkness what do you think about
that when you heard it uh yeah I've read
that somewhere
well that's Joe and Joe Joe likes he's
he's material and Max he's art he's
going to do whatever he feels passionate
about unless I respect that
personally I wouldn't turn down to Star
Trek but just because I'm just a
different person but
I think that it's great decision
whatever he does he's going to hopefully
do a great job man it's great to work
with and finally how likely would we
need to say you in a I know like a Star
Trek like a big sci-fi movie like that
or a Star Wars like if JJ Abrams came
calling or Joss Whedon for a superhero
movie what would you like to say that's
full of just really cool I would leave
my life behind and fly out to LA and
train for the world but I'm a big Marvel
fan I'm a big DC fan so I'm into all
that stuff I I know the no of what film
is auditioning I can tell you right now
just from futuristically speaking that's
just because my fan so obviously I'll be
I'll be very very happy if it happened
I'm pretty sure hopefully if everything
goes well it might might just do that
what current do you like to play so I'm
just going to be specific I would play
I'll play the Black Panther in Marvel
Josh Whedon listening just make great
choice I know there's loads of a black
panther there's a there's blade they
want to do a blade reboot the Wesley
Snipes hand on the baton to me I'll be
good ladies to be ly skin okay so yeah
well yeah i'll tell you how probably hot
blade I need over like skipper to have a
mobile fire severus it's been lovely so
busy he is fantastic movie I'm sure it's
going to get great reception
you